after years of toiling away where the
best places to spend your golden years
bankrate.com ranked 172 US cities and
there are different metrics included the
cost of living personal well-being for
seniors which includes health care
quality of course also walkability of
the city and weather also crime in state
and local taxes and here's what they
found mark the three best cities retire
in in order messe which is Phoenix
Arizona metro Phoenix Arizona really
arlington virginia and prescott arizona
and the worst new york figures pretty
partly or the tri-state area in New York
New York and New Haven Connecticut two
of the three and Little Rock Arkansas as
well and I would imagine that New York
coming in there because it's just too
expensive to live here and speaking of
inspect and the weather's not so great I
mean what happened last year with the 25
inches or more so if you're a retiree
the last thing you want to be thinking
about is shoveling out your your your
driveway but our victoria Stilwell and
way Lou did a report on Bloomberg
Business it says there's no place like
home except when you can't afford one
Millennials are being priced out as well
the rent so high that they can't save
any money for twenty percent down
payment on a home they're paying ever
higher rents if they do want to look to
buy something maybe they could find
something affordable in cities like
Detroit Buffalo Pittsburgh and
Indianapolis Wow lot of those cities a
lot of nasty weather in the winter time
too and a lot of questionable fiscal
conditions in some of those cities as
well understood